je suis Gabriel ce médecin est un
spécialiste de santé publique son
travail consiste à prévenir les
épidémies l'objectif est de vacciner
tous les enfants de moins de 15 ans dans
le camp aujourd'hui ils sont estimés à
30000 tout petit je rêvais d'aider les
autres sauver secourir protéger
finalement je suis journaliste alors
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ces femmes ordinaires
qui exercent des métiers du commun 1 2
3 aujourd'hui direction zaatari au nord
de la Jordanie qui accueille des
réfugiés de la guerre en Syrie
c'est fou parce que là-bas on voit pas
la fin en août 2012 la France a ouvert
ici une antenne chirurgicale 100
militaires au total dont une trentaine
de médecins d'infirmiers et d'ê
soignants je vais vivre quelques jours
avec ces chirurgiens de guerre qui
viennent en aide aux victimes du conflit
syrien m kil la seringue d'AD elle est
où urgence absolue pour ces hommes et
ses femmes venus sauver des vies en
plein
désert petite fille petite fille
[Musique]
bienvenue
N
[Musique]
je ne m'attarde pas à Aman la capitale
jordanienne Aman et ses célèbres ruine
romaine la Jordanie est coincée entre de
puissants voisins Israël l'Arabie
Saoudite l'Irak et la
Syrie aujourd'hui c'est le conflit
syrien qui déstabilise la région la
guerre civile qui oppose les combattants
révolutionnaires au régime de Bachar
al-Assad depuis 2 ans 100000 morts et
plus d'un million de réfugiés la moitié
de ces réfugiés sont installés ici en
Jordanie un tout petit pays 7 millions
d'habitants qui accueille déjà depuis
plus de 40 ans et la guerre des 6 jours
des centaines de milliers d'exilés
Palestiniens le camp de réfugié de
zaatari est à 1 heure de route d'Aman
direction plein nord à 10 km de la
frontière syrienne je suis impatient de
rencontrer ces chirurgiens de guerre
français voici premier constat ici ne
rentre pas qui veut il faut montrer pte
blanche le
policier
bienvenue
àatar mes premiers pas dans le camp il
fait 25 degr et je dois trouver le
groupement militaire
français grille ouverte l'officier de
presse m'attend il ne me quittera plus
d'une semelle c'est sympa comme com ce
petit
campingulier comme le Ve la tradition
militaire je suis accueil par le patron
le colonel
bise frise
peemiseot min enclave dans un camp que
je
pressend
imm
partiat ça a
l'air ça a
l'air ici vous avez le notre centre
opération c'est le centre névralgique du
détachement Tamour bonjour Pourquoi
Tamour parce que c'est un grand Tamour
Tamour ça veut dire fig d'accord fig ou
date voilà vaut mieux le laisser en
arabe ça ça fait ça parle mieux Tamour
dat ça fait un petit
peu tamamour c'est le nom de code de
cette opération humanitaire déclenchée
en août 2012 par la France avec
l'objectif de soigner la population
syrienne durant mon séjour ici plusieurs
visages vont devenir familiers Fabienne
adjudan 31 ans infirmière
célibataire ça nous rappelle pourquoi on
fait ce métier une balle de
Didier chirurgien orthopédiste colonel
43 ans marié père de TR enfants et on
appelle ça les des balles chemisé comme
dans le film Full Metal Jacket j'arrive
enfin à l'antenne chirurgicalej mon
guide et cette fois le docteur Patrice
ramiara on fait vraiment de la chirurgie
d'urgence chef de l'antenne chirurgicale
42 ans médecin anesthésiste marié père
de tris enfants le bloc il est là en fin
de compte
d'accord
qui est le bloc opératoire qu'on a
actuellement dans l'armée française je
comprends vite que c'est ici que je vais
passer pas mal de temps fa savoir
qu'avec ça c'est un bloc qui est
totalement équipé comme en
France et donc là les
patients pris un éclat et qu'elle avec
son père avec voilà c'est son papa qui
est là a des enfants on fait comme en
France il est arrivé hier soir opérer
dans la nuit pas de fièvre pas de fièvre
les paramètres sont bons ce petit bout
dechou à 5 ans il me fait le V de la
victoire c'est mon premier contact avec
les victimes de Bachar
alAssad juste une question
colonel quel blessé en fait c'est des
blessés de quelquun vous le savez vous
nous on fait pas de distingo on soigne
des victimes du conflit on ne sait pas s
ils sont ou combattants ou victime
collatéral de cette guerre nous prenons
tous les blessés nous les traitons ça
peut être des gens de chez Bachar de
l'armée de Bachar ou des
insurgés on peut pas faire le distingo
et ça m'étonnerait quand même que ça
soit des gens du camp d'en face vous
êtes sûr je suis pas 100% sûr mais c'est
plutôt des insurgés c'est plutôt des
gens
de de la révolution mais sans être
certain puisque nous leur demandons pas
ce genre de chose ici c'est un homme
égal un homme tout à fait quel que soit
son
campre pourtant je vais constater ici
que je ne rencontrerai à priori que des
combattants de l'Armée syrienne libre
les opposants à Bachar al-Assad et des
civils victime collatérale de la guerre
entre les deux camp
8h du matin pour tous rassemblement
militairet commandement seule exception
Fabienne l'infirmière et
l' soignant j' bien rester au lit
matinis
morte alors les gars c'est la relève des
collègues de nuit et la première
question vous avez fait des entrées non
il y a que de blocs BL sont il y a de
blocs finalement pas de nouveau blessés
cette nuit personne n'a pu passer la
frontière Gabin l'infirmier de nuit
brief Fabienne sur les patients encore
en soin se lè dès aujourd'hui ouut s'est
pas encore levé non et aujourd'hui on 25
tu pense du fixateur à faire d'accord
salut les
frères 15 lit au total ce matin chez les
hommes ils sont presque tous occupés
comme tous ses collègues Fabienne est à
zatari pour un mandat de 2 mois ok donc
lui il est au
bloc salut les gresses vous avez bien
dormi après les hommes elle passe dans
la tente d'en face celle des femmes et
des enfants alors elle qu'est-ce que
j'ai te dire particulier elle a bien
dormi qui va très bien aussi ma fr fait
normal Rawan 12 ans ici avec son papa
Rawan a été criblé par l'explosion d'un
obus elle a été hospitalisée avant
l'arrivée de Fabienne il y a les files
rouges c'està-dire ceux qui passent de
mandat en mandat notamment la petite
Rowan qui est là qui était là déjà au
mandat précédent et qui est là depuis le
début de notre mission et là on a sa
cousine en face qui elle est donc
initialement était pas hospitalisé mais
en fait l'évolution de son pansement
s'est pas déroulé comme on le voulait
donc donc du coup on l' on l'a
hospitalisé pour pouvoir surveiller un
petit peu les soins et la
cyatrisation ok deux enfant d'une même
famille touché par la guerre décidément
les petits syriens payent un lourd
tribut 1 2
3 comme ce jeune homme blessé par balle
déjà opéré en Syrie il repasse ce matin
sur la table d'opération pour lui
permettre de
remarcher
[Applaudissements]
ouais ça y est
ok c'est que c'est dingue quoi on a
l'eau ça parent là c'est ça c'est la
squelle chirurgie de guerre voilà je
retrouve Didier le chirurgien
orthopédiste c'est un pentete de
l'hôpital militaire béin à Paris il sera
mon professeur mais bon il vaut mieux
qu'il ait une cicatrice un peu
charnue il va pas trouver une gouresse
avec ça il y a eu une fracture je pense
à priori balistique on voit bien la
celleif ici ou la calcification c'est
une solidification anarchique de l'os
Didier va devoir le raboter pour
permettre au blessés de
remarcher
non ok ok good good
good l'anesthésie est partielle seul le
bas du corps est
endormi ça permet de garder les patients
éveill
éveillé l'avantage pas la peine de
mettre l'homme sous assistance
respiratoire et de consommer inutilement
de l'oxygène ici tout est importé de
France j'enfile une blouse de
chirurgien plus que jamais docteur
House on la secou en la tenant juste par
le col elle est pliée de telle manière
où elle va se mettre droite et après en
la tenant comme ça vous rentrer une main
dans la Manche ça va tenir l'autre main
dans la Manche alors touche à rien pour
l'instant voilà les
mains encore pousse bien
VO habé par le chirurgien c'est quand
même je dis c'est
classe même lui il a pas drit tous les
jours imaginez votre privilège et voilà
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà
on va PIR le
poser ce qu'on appelle le
champageamp
stér même sousente même en plein désert
le souci d'hygiène est le même qu'en
France on
yutiliser le bour électrique de voir la
chose près
privilè l'orthopédie c'est pas toujours
des gestes très fins oui oui voilà mais
il y a il y a a il y a tout vous pouvez
avoir la microchirurgie
donc on opère on opère avec des fils qui
sont plus fins que des cheveux c'est
marrant parle comme si on comprenait
oui tu aimes faire ça là c'est la
chirurgie ouais ouais dès que tu as les
main dedans exactement es heureux
mais la partie je vis dans la poussière
je dors sur un lipico c'est pas toute
l'année ça ou alors plus on vieillit moi
on le supporte effectivement je te
confirme mais comment tu as su avant de
le faire que tu serais heureux de faire
ça ça c'est une grande question en 3è
j'ai dit je être chirurgien orthopédiste
en 3è du collège d'accord tes parents
étaient médecin ou cardiologue il m'a
emmené au bloc pour te dégoûter
exactement sérieux tu verras et puis en
disant fois qu'il aur ça ilut changé
d'AV et je suis revenu en disant c'est
ça c'est
[Musique]
génial beau gosse mais à quel prix 35
POS
deure le patient peutadmirer tout de
suite
nelle opération réussie pour
normal dans l'aile opposée Fabienne et
Audrey l' soignante attaque les soins on
va essayer de faire quelques pas jusqu'à
la chaise
allez
super cet homme opéré hier du tibia doit
déjà se
lever on est obligé de faire se lever
très
tôt parce que les patients on peut pas
les garder longtemps il y a un brassage
qui est très important on est censé
accueillir tous les sorts de potentiel
urgenence donc on veut avoir le maximum
de
disponibilité il faut faire de la place
pour accueillir les nouveaux blessés
l'antenne chirurgicale ne dispose que de
lits on va refaire les lits he
ouais comme ça on peut faire les pensons
sur quelque chose de
propre
c'est bien il nous aide les patients
pour c'est génial une manière de dire
merci tu vas pas
avoir sans les chirurgiens français ces
deux là auraient peut-être perdu leur j
donc vous les pements c'est pas
aujourd'hui audrey elle fait la toilette
des patients c'est le seul robinet d'eau
de l'antenne chirurgicale et l'eau vient
de ces
bidons alors ça c'est les réserves d'eau
en fait parce que il y a pas d'eau
courant branché
directement l'eau c'est le principal
problème à
zatari alimenter en eau des dizaines de
milliers de personnes en plein désert
est un
exploit le précieux liquide est livré
chaque jour par camion citerne 2
millions de mètr cbes tous les
jours dans le camp français l'eau est
stockée dans ses réservoirs
et pour l'eau chaude une simple
bouilloire à l'antenne audrey a appris
le
système pour les patients parce fait il
y pas d'au chaud sur réseau
doncau
froide d'accord alors qu'est-ce que tu
caches toi des plateaux repas le
problème ça c'est qu'ils adorent stocker
la nourriture c'est pas trop compatible
avec les
soins
pourqui je pense qu'ils sont un peu dans
cette dans cette optique où on conserve
tout au cas où on va manquer on a des
plateaux qui datent
d'hier avec la guerre ces enfants n'ont
pas toujours mangé à le
super je veux me rendre compte par
moi-même de l'étendu de ce camp et c'est
Gunter le capitaine en charge des
relations civiles qui sera mon
guide il y a un autre phénomène ici
c'est que les gens luttent contre
l'ennui ouis contre contre l'enfermement
parce que les les journées se succèdent
et se ressemblent ils n'ont pas de
travail ils n'ont plus plus vraiment de
de rôle social il y a plus d'école il y
a plus enfin si il y a une école donc le
dilemme pour ces réfugiés s'installer
ou pas il y a beaucoup de signes
extérieurs que l'on décrypte au fur et à
mesure où on voit bien que les gens
commencent à s'installer là dans la
durée petit à petit les commerces se
sont étoffés on arrive à trouver des des
produits maintenant qui ne sont plus des
produits de première nécessité mais des
produits presque de confort
oui je vois parfumerie
parfumerie vês des machines à laver il y
a certaines tentes qui sont équipé de
machin à laver ici on va
tourner baptis les champsésé donc ça
c'est vraiment pour retrouver notre
français cette avenue l' baptis
Aven
gantes ils sont 70000 et plus de la
moitié on moins de 18 ans ce camp est
géré par le HCR le Haut Commissariat des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés sous
l'autorité bien sûr des Jordaniens quand
les Syriens arrivent ici ils n'ont plus
rien ou
[Musique]
presque bien les plus précieux qu'ils
ont ici ce sont les les téléphones
mobiles pourquoi parce qu'on est à à 10
km de la frontière donc les gens les
gens discutent ils se renseignent sur
sur leur maison est-ce que les maisons
ont été détruites ou pas voilà il
capteent les réseaux syriens quoi en
fait il capent les réseaux syriens ils
se renseignent évidemment sur l'état de
santé de leurs proches c'est fou parce
que là-bas on voit pas la fin du camp
oui on le voit mais détente et des
préfabriqués à perte de vue 2 à 3000
syriens arrivent ici tous les jours peu
à peu
zaatari dévore le désert et bientôt le
camp prévu pour 150000 personnes ne
suffira plus et ils arrivent ici comment
à pied non ils sont pris en charge par
les autorités jordaniennes à la
frontière Gard frontière qui les font
monter dans des bus et on les emmène ici
dans le camp il pass une première nuit
dans le camp à même le sol sur une N et
au petit matin on le donne une tente qu'
mon euxmême d'accord donc malgré tout la
traversée ça reste une ododyé c'est pas
simple c'est quand même une épreuveme
uneeuve moi
Christophe tu ici oui oui oui oui oui
[Musique]
ou au bloc Patrice l'anesthésiste
prépare le deuxième opéré de la journée
quand soudain l'urgence reprend le
dessus S n pas endormi lui encore ah
ouais il vaut mieux ou on sort celui-là
on met l'autre à la
place l'homme sur la civière vient
d'arriver il est gravement blessé le dos
et un bras déchiqueté par l'explosion
d'une B attendez que tout le monde soit
prêt pour le transférer tout le monde
est prêt oui 1 2
3 c'est encore un combattant de l'armée
syrienne libre
on va juste sortir le patient
[Musique]
prédent heureusement ce patient n'était
pas encore sous anesthésie encore
quelques secondes et Didier ne pouvait
plus retarder l'opération
prévue on fait la radio du torax 1 2 3
Go
[Musique]
On rien sur le torax c'est une grosse
blessure balistique vous avez ça que
2 m kil 25 de
suc la seringue d'ADR elle est où
l'homme a très mal il faut faire vite
pour Patrice l'anesthésiste l'urgence
est de le stabiliser et de le préparer
pour le
bloc le but c'est pas d'aller trop vite
pour griller les étapes mais c'est de
gagner du temps sur les choses simple et
donc en gros on gagne un peu en matière
de de survie pour les patients c'est
Emmanuel le de chirurgien de l'antenne
qui est chargé d'extraire le projectile
ouais bingo ah ouais oh ça c'est du
lourd ce morceau de métal a fait
beaucoup de dégâts le bras on peut
raccourcir un peu ça fera un bras plus
court mais il vaut mieux avoir un bras
raccourci que pas de bras du
toutci est une balle de kalashnikov
n'est-ce
pas on a un féur cassé sans sans
projectile il y a pas de PL de il a pas
eu de donc là c'est le travail à la
chaîne he capitaine c'est ça et ça c'est
une balle une balle de calche niikof
donc c'est fait pour faire très mal quoi
les avions ont lancé des obus quand les
enfants rentraient de l'école c'est un
obus de Bachar
[Musique]
alAssad déjà une petite évaluation des
affaires là dans le F ouais le F
Emmanuel est viscéraliste lui et Didier
l'orthopédiste sont les deux chirurgiens
de l'antenne il s'assistent mutuellement
c'est Emmanuel qui va poser les
broches les deux chirurgien ont réussi à
éviter
l'amputationemuel est en train de
vérifier avec un petit do de pocheon
sent bien les pou que la main est bien
vascularisée
tu l'avais un
moment on a mis le bras en sécurité la
main est vascularisée le bras stabilisé
le pronostic vital est pas mis en jeu et
il va être transféré donc sur un hôpital
jordanien pour la suite du
traitement le bras de ce combattant a
été raccourci d'environ 10 cm mais il
garde son bras et sera envoyé pour la
suite dans un hôpital
d'AM
j'abandonne provisoirement le bloc
opératoire besoin de prendre un peu
[Musique]
l'air le job de ces chirurgiens est
impressionnant pendant 2 mois dans la
poussière et un confort rudimentaire
loin de leur famille et de leurs amis
ils sauvent des vies
au même moment rwan la petite syrienne
gravement blessée à la jambe profite des
dernier rayon du soleil avec sa
famille mais c'est l'heure de rentrer
pour les
soins et c'est a qui s'en
occupe a déjà été uté d'un orteil elle a
subi TR opérations et elle devra passer
une dernière fois au bloc demain parce
quean tu
m'es on voit beaucoup d'enfants et mais
on s'y attache vite en plus puis il
reste là longtemps parce que les enfants
on les garde en général avec nous par ça
nous permet de de les surveiller un peu
plus de près s'ils ont des traitements à
prendre on est sûr qu'il les prennent
tout ça parce que de par mon expérience
dans dans d'utres pays les parents
vendaient souvent les
médicaments des enfants donc au moins là
on est sûr de les avoir auprès de
nous pour des raisons de sécurité les
militaires français sort RAR de
leurite les activités extra
professionnell le
sport Patrice mus
pouremuès
comp parce qu'on est une petite enclave
on v toujours les sur les autres le
sport c'est la bulle où personne ne
pénètre ENIT donc c'estz
agréable Fabi enchane lesercut avec ses
collègues un bon moyen d'évacuer la
pression le stress on arrive gérer ave
l'expérience mais c'est vra
que les
jsouler sentretient
physiquement et ça nous change
activité il est 20h Patrice
l'anesthésiste supervise le transfert
vers Aman du patient qui a évité de
justesse l'amputation du BR le monde est
prêt oua 1 2 3
[Musique]
ce voyage vers am est à risque de
infirmier français l'accompagne une
heure de route Patrice prévo appareil de
réanimation cardiaque les ambulances
jordaniennes N sont pas
[Musique]
équip suis à 14h30 on l'a déchoqué en un
quart d'heure il est passé au bloc en
une demi-heure ça a duré 1h de le temps
de faire la chirurgie et puis après là
on est dans les bons délais quoi ça lui
laisse quand même pas mal de de chance
qu Patrice et son équipe ont consacré 6
heur au total à ce blesser de
guerre bonjour bonjour ce soir qure
infirmiers ont une mission chargé de
lourde malâ ils remontent les Champs
Élysées de ZAR ils ont rendez-vous avec
ce colosse syrien un boulanger il prête
son four français car ce soir pour
l'équipe médicale c'est
pizza la journée rude comme toutes les
autres autour d'un DEAMP
décompresse soignante se confie je me
suis engagé à 18 ans parce que j'avais
envie de partir de chez moi sortir du N
familial un petit peu et vivre des
aventures on peut les viv ici des beau
souvenirs c'est une belle expérience
c'est enrichissant on prend beaucoup de
maturité c'est ici au coin du feu que
toute cette équipe soudée trouve
l'énergie pour affronter le
[Musique]
quotidien
comme tous les matins Patrice se rent au
rassemblement les chirgi son
lénérour une représentation de
l'équipeem ça fait de la vie
militaire chef d'antenne j'essaie d'y
êtretion pour
lesle
[Musique]
9h du matin c'est l'ouverture de la
grille à l'hôpital français les enfants
attendent le top départ pour rentrer
comme chaque jour ils sont des dizaines
à venir se faire
vacciner c'est rigolo on dirait qu'il
vont qu'il vont
jouer une brouette ise de
pouss je suis Gabriel ce médecin est un
spécialiste de santé publique son
travail consiste à prévenir les
épidémiesinte en CH personne et Lene de
vaccination d'accord vaccation Peret
d'enreistr les vaccins qui sont fait
aujourd'hui le vaccin d'aujourd'hui est
contre la rougeole une inection virale
20 fois plusast
lari espagnole donc là c'est le travail
à la chaîne hein
capitaine l'objectif est de vacciner
tous les enfants de moins de 15 ans dans
le camp aujourd'hui ils sont estimés à
30000 ce matin Gabriel espère vacciner
250 enfants ce qui me paraît énorme et
sous l'autorité de ce médecin je vais
faire ma première vaccination
oui j'ai toutes
les
VO vous relâchez et voilà c'est fini ça
va j'ai étaé bon ah bah très très bien
c'est
impeccable bon c'est une affaire qui
roule ça c'est une affaire qui roule
mais comment ça se fait que l'armée
française s'est trouvé avec ça comme
mission de vacciner c'est le tout
premier épidémiologiste qui est venu
avec le premier a la mission a fait a
fait un travail d'évaluation des besoins
en santé du camp et c'est et personnees
ne vacciné et sur un camp de réfugié
c'est vraiment une action prioritaire
pour l'OMS c'est une des 10 priorités
avec trouver un toit aux gens avec de
leur donner à manger avec leur apporter
de l'eau propre vacciner les enfants
contre la rougeole est vraiment une des
grosses priorités et des choses
importantes à faire
d'cord depuis 2012 les Français ont
vacciné 20000 gamins contre la rougeole
pour éviter une épidémie il faut vaciner
95% des enfants du
camp retour à l'hôpital français je
rends une petite visite à l'homme opéré
hier de la
cuisse comment ça
va ça va merci vous avez vu Lapp come
elle est
belle oui la cicatrice est
belle ça maintenant vous allez vous êtes
marié
ou parce que
la est-ce que ma est infectée et comment
va
m
nickel tout enlev et mis de la cire au
fond super super super moi je suis pas
un
médecin un peu plus loin Rawan la petite
syrienne est au bloc pour sa greffe de
peau Didier et Emmanuel nos deux
chirurgiens se préparent 50 j'ai mis
30ond on lui prélève un carré de 4 cm à
l'intérieur de la cuisse pour la bonne
viabilité du
greffon on va faire un petit quadrillage
pour augmenter la taille de la greffe en
fait comme un Baris en fait c'est mieux
quand tu
t'appliques monsieur je suis déjà au
maximum je suis désolé c'est jeunes fa
vraiment les surveiller comme le lait
sur le
feu là on peut estimer que si tout se
passe bien dans 5 jours rwan elle sort
de l'antenne elle sort de l'hôpital et
elle retourne dans le camp on la revoit
pas rwan sort du bloc et part en salle
de
réanimation
pendant que se réveille lentement
Patrice pr au
dépvu fairee
anesthiqueéné cet homme il a pris une
balle dans le dos une blessure
superficielle h c'est ça qu'on va aller
chercher ceci est une balle de
kalashnikov n'est-ce pas c'est une balle
de kalashnikov je sais pas oui c'est une
balle de kalnikov on voit
bienie me voilà donc aide
anesthésiste là si on te si on te laisse
faire c'est qu'il y a aucun risque
souvent on aime bien former les gens si
par exemple là on a un jeune caporal qui
fait partie du poste de secours on les
forme au geste
d'urgence
faut essayer d'être le plus étanche
possible tu comme
ça super bien tu prxygè très
bien
par chirurgien qui contrôle
toujoursillat c'est un B
prof le premier produit que j'ine c'est
c'est DUFA c'est 1000 fois plus puissant
que la morphine d'accord c'est un
morphinique de synthèse voilà donc il y
a des posologies à respecter hein c'est
pour ça qu'on fait des
études en plus du morphinique on utilise
ce qu'on appelle un hypnotique appelle
du lait de coco le morphinique efface la
douleur l'hypnotique endort le patient
parce que c'est vrai que ça ressemble un
peu à du ponch coco mais ça pas du tout
les mêmes vertes
Emmanuel le viscéraliste entre en scène
c'est à son tour d'opérer on met
latéral à sa gauche je suis au première
loge la BAL est à quelques
centimètresessous de la
peau j'accepte bien volontiers de donner
un coup de main au
chirurgien de ma première opération
quand je pense qu'ils font toutes ses
études pour
ça j'ai extrait ma première
balle un peu plus tard Didier tient à me
montrer sa petite collection tu ASAS
les donc ça c'est la collection de tous
les éclats qu'on a
retiré ça c'est le l'éclat qu' avait
dans le dans le dos du patient ça c'est
quoi éclat d'obus ça on sait pas oui
c'est un éclat d'obus certainement et ça
c'est une balle une balle de kalashnikov
est complètement tordue et déformé parce
qu'elle a rencontré de l'os donc qui l'a
complètement déformé à et on appelle ça
les des balles chemisé comme dans le
film Full Metal Jacket c'estàdire qu'il
y a un noyau en plomb et l'extérieur
c'est une chemise en général en cuivre
donc c'est fait pour faire très mal
quoi des trophées de guerre comme autant
de VI
fin d'après-midi juste le temps de faire
un peu de sport avant la tombée de la
[Musique]
nuit comme d'habitude la petite famille
se retrouve au coin du feu ce soir c'est
soirées créoles cyia l'infirmière
antillaise prépare des beignets de
banane ça fait du bien moral comme on
est moin de notre famille quand même
donc c'est important de se retrouver et
puis retrouver un petit peu de chaleur
humaine et
c ça fait du bienugo
[Musique]
Emmanuel et Didier les deux chirurgiens
préfèrent quitter le groupe comme chaque
soir ils s'isolent pour appeler leurs
enfants Marie
Camille coucou
tu sais qu'à la fin des vacances moi je
rentre
he une quinzaine de minutes avec les
enfants ça fait du
[Musique]
bien c'est
Didier
bon à demain j'aurais fait visiter le
l'hôpital avec l'ordinateur
mais pas les pas les les choses
importantes mais on leur montre les
tentes de loin et cetera c'est les fait
ça le don une idée de là où on vit en
tout cas le le fait d'être sous tente ça
les fait un peu un peu rêver on a la
chance d'avoir un réseau Internet euh
qui marche bien quand on a pas de moyens
de communication notamment il y a des
missions on a que le téléphone ça dévite
ça un peu c'est un peu difficile vous
leur dites que vous êtes chirurgien de
guerre que qu'en C c'est il y a un
conflit ou non c'est des thèmes
qu'onaborde pas parce que c'est la
guerre c'est ça génère l'anxiété et
c'est jamais très bon ah et une
ambulance
22h le balai des ambulances reprend la
pose est terminée de blessés graves
autour de moi c'est
l'agitation attention
[Applaudissements]
radio une
ure ça parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'class sur la jambe ouais
donc pas de de sortie bizarre quand même
bah ouais
mais pour nous c'est déstabilisant parce
que on a un fmur cassé sans sans
projectile avec un trou d'entrée donc il
a pas de trou de sortie pas de trou de
sortie en principe le trou de sortie est
plus gros que celui plus ouais
normalement il y a un effet cône la
balle surtout quand elle euh elle
percute quand elle perc se met à tourner
sur elle-même et le trou de sortie est
beaucoup plus large que le trou d'ange
la victime souffre mais elle devrait
survivre c'est une urgence mais là tout
est stabilisé on peut se permettre de
repasser un deuxème contrôle tout
vérifier si on on n pas passé à côté de
d'aucune PL si on a rien
oublié pendant ce temps-là cyia et
Audrey font la radio du deuxème patient
étrangement silencieux la balle dans le
pelv dans le pelvis il a la v rectum il
y a plein de choses ouais donc il a des
gros vaisseaux qui passent donc ça peut
faire des dégâts ou c'est typi le genre
de mal veut pas
attendre il n'y a qu'un seul bloc
opératoire dans l'urgence l'équipe
choisi qui peut attendre le blessé va
rester une demi-heure sur le
billard un chirurgien militaire c'est le
métier qu'on peut pas faire ailleurs la
chirurgie sous tente au milieu de nulle
part en autonomie complète pour faire la
de guerre je crois qu'il y a que nous
qui le faisons et il un côté très enfin
vraiment vraiment excitant quoi c'est
surtout quand on est jeune peut-être que
plus tard ce sera un peu pesant mais je
crois que pour un jeune chirurgien c'est
quand même vraiment extra
quoi c'est c'est le
c'est a pas on est occupé c'est
quoi ciseau vas-y did c'est je je vais
finir avecine
son il y a pas de PL il a pas eu d'éclat
ou de
[Musique]
B bless par jeaurais
pris les médecins français ne prennent
que des blessés de guerre c'est leur
spécialité il est minuit l'ambulance rep
vers l'un des deux autres hôpitaux du
camp le lendemain matin 1 heure de
voiture au milieu du
désert direction Amane la capitale 2
millions
[Musique]
d'habitants j'ai rendez-vous dans un
hôpital de la ville avec Didier et patri
qui sont ven prendre des nouvelles du
patient syrien qu'ils ont sauvé de
l'amputation il est toujours en
observation suivi par des médecins
jordanien
sertiectionn avec sa
famille non pas encore il vient juste de
me demander d'appeler chez
lui et il a un numéro de téléphone il
veut appeler est-ce que je peux lui
donner mon
téléphone tu veux appeler chez toi si on
te donne un
téléphone voilà on va lui donner son mon
téléphone al non
allô
maman comment tu
vas tu peux me passer
[Musique]
papa non non rien de grave je te jure
j'ai juste un petit rum je Te
prometsi Papa s'il te
plaît allô papa oui écoute-moi j'ai été
blessé par
bal non non rien de
grave je suis à l'hôpital en Jordanie
je me repose et je rentre
bientôt je comprends son gros mensonge
il ne veut pas inquiéter ses parents
bloqu à l'une des villes martyr de
syri merci merci
beaucoup vous pouvez juste lui demander
qui il est d'ù il
vient il vient de Syrie
de c'est un
soldat c'est un
soldat de l'armée
libre il a été blessé pendant un combat
il a été blessé pendant les
combats
mer merci à vous et bon
courage
retour à zatari et la mi est pour Awan
c'est bientôt la fin de l'épreuve ce
soir elle va dormir chez elle c'est un
peu la chouchou de
Fabien ça fait partie des raisons pour
lesquelles je pars en mission les
patients et plus particulièrement les
enfants on s'attache vite ils sont
reconnaissant et de les voir évoluer
dans le bon sens guérir et tout c'est
vrai que ça fait des super souvenir et
c'est ça nous rappelle pourquoi on fait
ce
[Musique]
métier une ambulance arrive et à
l'intérieur pour une fois ça n'est pas
un blessé de guerre mais de femmes l'une
d'entre ell est enceinte l'accouchement
est
imminent en face de l'antenne
chirurgicale se tient une t blanche
c'est celle de gynécologie sans frontièr
une jeune ONG nantaise installée dans le
camp français ici ils sont 5 à assurer
un service
d'obstétrique je suis invité par noraune
des gynéco à entrer sous la tente au
moment où l'accouchement se termine tout
s'est bien
[Musique]
passé
garçon petite fille petite fille
bienvenue qui a besoin d'un petit peu
d'oxygène et combienen
aujourd'hui il en a eu 4 cette nuit là
c'est le 5è depuis minuit 5è depuis
minuit ou hier il en avait on en a eu 12
hier 12 ouis 12 bébés depuis son arrivée
il y a 2 semaines Nora a accouché bébés
en moyenne
chaque jour il pleur pas assez là ça va
ça va là ça va mais on a dû le
l'oxygéner un peu pour le untit
peu voilà en Maillotte comme ça comme
Anaïs va vous montrer
[Musique]
ou
voilà ils se sentent plus en sécurité
comme
ça il découvre le monde d'une manière un
peu bizarre lui trou dans un camp de
réfugi et en fait les femmes du camp
beaucoup de sacrif beaucoup de Mor de tu
en Syrie P que les bébés sont protégés
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup
d'enfants qui naissent c'est leur
croyance dans le camp voil voilà sontég
VI
renouv
combat on dirait que c'est le
mien on présenter à sa
maman
ça fait du bien ce sentiment que la vie
continue que les familles se perpétuent
qu'il y a de
l'espoir avant de quitter
zatari une dernière chose me tient à
cœur
raccompagner Rawan auprès des
[Musique]
siens après 2 mois d'hospitalisation che
les médecins militaires français qu
opérations et pas mal de larmes elle
rentre chez elle dans le
[Rires]
campère et c'est lui qui nous emmène
dans ce mobilehom de 10 m car où ils
vivent à
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
là ça fait de mois demi qu'on est là on
a qué la Syrie on est arrivé direct ici
quce qui vous est
arrivé les avions lancé des quand les
enfants rentra de l'école
d'accord
auamp
pour les
soigner les enfants sont restés
hospitalisés 10 jours le problème c'est
que dans les hôpitaux syriens il n'y a
pas de médecin et pas de médicament
elle sera totalement guérie vous rentrer
vous voulez rentrer en
Syrie nous allons rentrer en Syrie mes
enfants et ma femme vont rester ici
pourquoi il rent pas avec
vous vous savez c'est dangereux là-bas
les bombes tombent jour et nuit
un jour mon mari travaillait sur le toit
de notre maison et des obus ont explosé
juste à côté de lui comment la vie ici
madame la vie est dure les toilettes
sont communes et c'est très sale ce
n'est pas comme chez nous ici il y a
beaucoup de poussière il fait très chaud
vous pensez que vous allez rester
combien de temps ici on espère rester un
mois un mois et demi maximum mais on dit
ça depuis notre arrivée merci beaucoup
en tout
cas
AZ je n'aurais pas croisé que des
combattants mais beaucoup de femmes et
beaucoup
[Musique]
d'enfants dernier passage au camp pour
saluer l'équipe médicale qui a tenu à me
faire une
surprise on vous remet le produit de
votre
[Rires]
travail la balle que j'ai extraite je
repars ce soir eux sont encore là pour
une quinzaine de jours tous rentreront
en France avant sans doute d'accepter
une nouvelle mission il est temps pour
moi de repartir à la découverte de
nouveaux horizons où m'attendent
d'autres hommes d'autres femmes au
métier peu ordinaire